sur le continent africain toujours une
enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
unis suite au décès d'un homme vendredi
des violences en marge des
manifestations dans la capitale
tunisienne mobilisation à l'occasion du
11e anniversaire de la révolution qui a
poussé l'ex président ben ali au départ
le point avec notre correspondant à
tunis ben hassen chébili
c'est un nouveau rebondissement dans la
sphère des manifestations du 14 janvier
dernier au coeur de la capitale
tunisienne après les violences
policières observé sur l'avenue habib
bourguiba notamment contre des
journalistes et condamné par la société
civile et l'opposition le décès d'un
manifestant vient de nouveau relancé le
débat sur les violences policiers à
vendredi en marge de la mobilisation à
tunis un homme a été retrouvé
inconscient en voie d'être pris en
charge par la protection civile et
conduit à l'hôpital habib thameur
indique le bureau de presse du tribunal
de première instance de tunis le parquet
a ouvert une enquête hier pour
déterminer les causes exactes de ce
décès et a annoncé la réalisation d'une
autopsie médico légales selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète le corps
de l'individu ne portaient aucune trace
visible de violence des éléments loin de
convaincre l'opposition le groupe
citoyen contre le coup d'état avait
annoncé plus tôt mercredi le décès de
ridha bouzaiene dans un hôpital de la
capitale affirmant qu'il avait pris part
aux manifestations du 14 janvier selon
l'association l'homme de 57 ans aurait
succombé aux blessures qui lui ont été
infligées au cours des interventions
musclées des forces de l'ordre pour
disperser la foule qui aurait tenté de
forcer les barrages de sécurité même son
cloche auprès d'ennahda qui a condamné
dans un communiqué sur sa page internet
la mort du manifestant écoutez nous
condamnons le meurtre de ridha ben
hussein qui avait succombé à ses
blessures après avoir été victime d'une
violence excessive perpétrés par les
membres des forces de l'ordre lors de sa
participation aux manifestations à
l'occasion de la célébration du 11ème
anniversaire de la révolution tunisienne
alors que le ministère de l'intérieur
est pointé du doigt pour sa gestion des
événements et le recours à la violence
de ces unités de terrain ce dernier
s'est défendu en indiquant avoir fait
preuve de la plus grande des retenue
face à des manifestants bien décidés à
braver l'interdît écouter nos unités ont
fait preuve de la plus grande retenue
face aux manifestants qui ont tenté
délibéré man de briser le cordon
policier et de s'en prendre aux forces
de sécurité déployés pour maintenir
l'ordre public ces protestataires ont
bravé l'interdiction de manifester
décidée par le gouvernement dans le
cadre de mesures sanitaires visant à
freiner la résurgence de l'épidémie de
lakovic 19 un drame deux versions qui
viennent exacerber les tensions déjà
palpable quand un président ça y est
bien décidée à maintenir coûte que coûte
son cap du 25 juillet date de son coup
de force et une opposition dont les
rangs n'ont fait que gonfler ces
derniers mois